thank you very much let's hope that the
presentation also works very well and
you get value of it so this talk is not
only about Rapids so what does
mentioning is about the whole
open-source GPU ecosystem and how we're
trying to get things together how we're
trying to all play together to make
things as productive as possible and as
useful as possible for the users Rapids
was introduced with a philosophy of open
source and openness not trying to
replace anything of the wonderful
existing PI data ecosystem but trying to
extend it so when we started Rapids we
had a fundamental question we're going
to start a new machine learning data
analytics data cleaning framework so the
most fundamental question we had is like
should we create a new array for the GPU
should we clear and no standard backed
by Nvidia to be the official GPU device
array so this coming immediately came to
mind to our minds well we're gonna
introduce and the funny part is that
literally we started looking at how many
device array implementations were in
Python there were 14 device our
implementations already existing so if
we had introduced ours in good I mean
the 15th one so actually the number
coincided with our famous xkcd comic
which i think is like 6 years old is
pretty old but it's very true so this
talk is actually about doing this we
don't want to introduce a new standards
we don't wanna replace what is out there
in the PI data ecosystem we want to make
things play nicely together now to start
with we have to understand why Python
why this ecosystem why we decided to
introduce rapid into our PI data system
why we didn't go in a different route
why didn't we just produce more C++
tools the tools why we didn't just go to
spark the spark world so the thing about
the Python data echo system is that it
is a very wonderful ecosystem it is nice
the Python language is easy for not only
computer scientists but people from
mathematical backgrounds from from
physics backgrounds and it has a lot of
support not only from traditional
computer science worlds and many many
many wonderful tools have come thanks to
that in particular examples you have
numpy that has helped
make python a great numerical
computation like a language you have
things like pandas that have helped a
lot to make Python great for data
cleaning they'd among Ling and just in
general data manipulation and you have
one of the best libraries in my opinion
has ever existed for machine learning
scikit-learn very elegant with lots of
algorithms available with a lot of
documentation and really good api this
and there is really easy to use now the
counter example i Hawaii some people say
hey what a white on wood you'd go to
Scala why don't you go to and at sea
itself or other languages is that
particularly when I started playing a
lot in the Python field in 2013 is that
Python was not known for speed Python
was great for accessibility but if you
wanted production speed if you wanted a
lot of responsiveness when you were
training new machine learning models
when doing new developments Python was
not necessarily the way to go and a lot
of people in 2013 we're trying to do to
begin tackling this problem Python was
orders of magnitude slower than code in
C and pray and wonderful products like
numba we're going troduce it when we're
introduced back then to allow users to
start making python a little bit faster
and number for example is a really good
example of what can be done with
significant effort and a lot of clever
people and it allows users to write
custom functions that make Python almost
as fast as C in some cases of course
that kind of removes a little bit of the
wonderful simplicity of Python and that
wonderful simplicity is what we like we
like to see codes that look like this
doing poor you import your two libraries
you just import pandas import your
secular you have reviewed it and a CSV
and indeed smart mean its most basic
form Python allows you to do this five
lines of code and you already have a
logistic regression based on your CSV on
your own your data set that was unheard
of in computer science 20 years ago and
C++ traditionally opening files is not
exactly an easy and easy task
of course so does the feel we're rapid
came to exist the depay data ecosystem
where things are easy to
and makes data scientists and users very
very productive so for anyone that was
here for my colleague Brad restock he
went through a quick overview of how
people have tackled going beyond what
Python was originally capable and I
guess and I think I don't need to ask
how many people here familiar with SPARC
is not exactly new it's not exactly the
the the newest cool kid in the block a
lot of people have migrated to use spark
when they go and when they outgrow the
possibilities of the traditional Python
data a data science ecosystem pandas
single GPU a single CPU pandas single
CPU secular have limitations and
therefore when you wanna go to big
datasets many people went to Hadoop
spark and many distributed ecosystems
particularly the Apache big data
ecosystem they pictured Apache big data
ecosystem including Hadoop big spark is
wonderful particularly in the sense of
completeness it has a lot of tools and
it still I would say moderate moderately
productive for users that's it it's not
unheard of that the Apache Big Data
ecosystem is more the realm of data
engineers than data scientists you
require a lot more computer programming
knowledge to be good spark developer
than four to being a good Python
developer so spark does help a lot with
the speed problems of Python with the
scalability problems Python but it's not
exactly the ideal solution for every
scenario and not only that if you
analyze the performance of spark it
happens that spark runs into the same
limitation as the original Python data
science ecosystem it is CPU limited even
when analyzing something as simple as a
count when you have a distributed spark
cluster you end up being CPU limited
before you usually before you end up
maxing your memory maxing your bandwidth
your CPU will be the bottleneck so of
course that begs the question
wooden why don't we use an accelerator
and of course the most popular
accelerator around our GPUs my first
answer here is why we decide to use any
GPUs is because they are so very pretty
that gold GPO there they're beautiful
besides being beautiful there so there's
also big ecosystems I have been foster
for many years in the high-performance
computing area CUDA is something has
many many many many years of development
so many people who dress it and years
ago I remember when I was doing a PhD
many people will start asking the
question why don't we use GPUs from
machine traditional machine learning way
more for data processing not only for
deep learning what is the thing stopping
people from using GPUs and well there
are lots of wonderful tools for GPUs
traditionally speaking things like
thrust cup C++ itself which has evolved
we don't believe in the latest standards
you have opened you see X there are
orders of magnitude faster what was
traditionally available in Python but
let's see what happens you want a
program just a softmax function well
this is my kernel for programming a
softmax function that is really fast and
really optimizing in C++ and CUDA and
that have the function actually CUDA is
greater speed it's not compute limited
actually and has a lot of potential but
for data scientist and for being
productive at creating new machine
learning models it definitely had a lot
of barriers and it's not exactly easy to
program for if anyone is a computer
science teacher they might like this
it's a lot of optimized code is doing
cool things using shared memory but if
you every time you had to create a
linear regression you have to program a
loss model like these well does the
recent CUDA was not popular for
classical machine learning five years
ago but that still doesn't negate the
advantage and the thing we have seen in
the field now that we are a hearing to
rapid the thing is that GPUs don't get
compute limited in the vast majority of
cases in the bus majority of cases the
limitation with GPUs is actually memory
bandwidth which means you can keep
throwing the more data you throw at the
problem the faster GPUs will keep
performing so that that is an amazing
advantage and also they are said you can
put up to 16gb using a single in a
single server and there's a lot of tools
that we have inherited from the high
performance
computing area the HPC guys doing
weather simulations doing very very
hardcore mathematical algorithms have
implemented lots of great mathematical
algorithms CUDA has a lot a lot of
existing code that is wonderful so this
is the exact context that Rapids came
into existence now the thing is that
there's still a lot of open questions
not only hey let's create then a Python
wrapper around the existing CUDA code
and just offer it as cities it happens
that during all these years in the
Python data echo system there are in
many many lessons learned I remember
exactly in 2013 in PI data New York I
remember going to a talk by West
McKinney the creator of pandas it's a
talk that I got very famous and I
recommend you to for you to look in
YouTube because it's very very very very
nice to look at the title of talk was 10
things I hate about pandas and it was
just lessons that he learned while
writing pandas and created the basis of
pandas and among those many lessons he
ended up eventually going and creating a
new project called Apache arrow now
Apache arrow things many people
understand to be familiar with but it's
not a panda style library that you will
end up juicing and necessarily every day
is more of a developer back-end library
that allows your tools to be better now
what are the main lessons that pandas
try to address well one big one is that
for if you want to do a workflow that is
not just about tools of a single library
you have to do a lot of data conversion
a lot of manipulating data for example
back in the day even going from
something as simple from a panda's data
frame to scikit-learn you have to
convert your panda's data frame into a
matrix and then go to scikit-learn
which is an added complexity and if you
have wanted to also use deep learning
after that well things immediately got
way more complex so one of the big
things that a bacheior try to do or try
is doing these days is creating a common
column base memory format and therefore
any library that at the year adheres to
this memory format can talk with each
other and then the user doesn't need to
worry if their data was originated in
one library if they want to use
functions in another library or even
potentially languages
there is nothing stopping one having a
hybrid language workflow in which you
use for example our statistical
functions then you do Python pandas deep
learning and then you can use ggplot for
visualizing things because oh dear lord
I wish we had ggplot2 in Python but
that's another that's that would be a
talk for another day so in this sense
Apache arrow is existing and then we
started developing the rapid car the the
tools available in rapid I won't repeat
necessarily what are the core trappings
components but if you visualize what are
the core components of the Python data
science ecosystem it looks something
like this
at least desired like the most no tools
for every data scientist you need to
know in the Python world you need to do
pandas to clean your data scikit-learn
network xavier and to graph analytics
then some deep learning framework and
some visualization these are kind of the
fundamentals so we decided let's not
reinvent the tool and that's kind of the
motto of our of our project let's do
pretty much the same stack but just
replacing the components into with GPU
components for anyone that has gone to
our booth or to Brad's presentation you
you saw that could EF is essentially
pandas that uses the GPU who AM L is
essentially scikit-learn that uses the
GPU and who graph is just essential in
network access uses the GPU with the
same code the same API but this talk is
not about those as much as it pains me
because I'm very big into the machine
learning one this talk is more about
these guys this diagram begs the
question why in Europe rapid stack are
you including PI torch chain er MX net
if those are not part of the rapid
exceed or the rapid github repository
well it happens that this is an
ecosystem that is about interoperability
between different products from
different people this we have worked a
lot for example with the pathology guys
so you could have a workflow in which
you star in PI torch
maybe have a deep learning and a neural
network that has lots of weight and
maybe you went to Leyland machines talk
about you map or John's talk about you
map and you're like hey I know
you map can be used to visualize weights
in neural networks very very nicely
why don't I and I know that who AM L
introduce a new super fast zoom up
implementation I got a few months ago so
we have worked a lot with biter each
case so that you workflow canasta and pi
torch you can send your torch tensors
from PI 13 to KML to apply you map and
we just give you the results and you
didn't have to do any conversions you
didn't have to worry once your data what
was the format of the data we just work
together and that is not only with PI
torches with many other libraries the
other component that is important I
wanted to emphasize here is desk task is
not only a rapid umbrella project it's a
distributed framework that is general
for Python you can use that without any
rapid component totally with just with
scikit-learn or tasks doing numpy
operations by itself we have done a lot
of contributions to desk some of the key
contributors to tasks actually part of
our team this is all with this motto of
we wanted to extend and embrace the open
the open source community that already
exists so there are a few questions that
I wanted to answer before moving or how
things are operating with each other the
first one is we used a lot of sites on
in our code and Brad showed you the
diagrams more in-depth of how each of
our tools have differently here as
primitives and syphon and C++ and Korea
but syphon is one of our key components
in our Python code the majority of it is
not Python actually syphon well we
decided to embrace iPhone 4 for 4 key
reasons one is that it allows us to have
some static typing for anyone that has
worked in the past with static typed
languages there are certain things that
are nice about them in which you want
when you can declare your variables as
having a type particularly you can as a
tool developer you can check if your
reducer is giving you something correct
before processing things before crashing
your program before doing crazy things
which is not necessarily the case with
Python although later versions have
improved significantly in that but
siphon was already statically typed that
also allowed us to go and expose CUDA
code directly sytem has has great
interoperability with C++ so it's a very
very valuable tool for us but not only
that the other key component I wanted to
focus today in is that siphon has it has
a lot of use in the Python ecosystem
under under the hood for many many many
projects to the extent that for example
numpy offers a site on a specific API if
you wanna for example access the
pointers of the PI of the noon PI object
is very very easy insight on because it
has integrated a lot of the new PI API
so many many other projects have some
specific ApS that have allowed us to
work together and make things nicer for
the users the other question that comes
to rise and the other component I
emphasize why was why tasks well among
among many other reasons is that we
could have gone and write an O
distributed computing framework that was
appropriate for the CUDA based machine
learning algorithms we do but tasks is
already very good for ETL for data
processing tasks and also it's pi day
tonight native it's very very very well
integrated with the Python data science
ecosystem particularly with numpy and
pandas
it was born from the necessity of
parallelizing pandas and trying to make
things run faster both in single node
and multi node multi CPU
setups so tasks already had the API and
the idiosyncrasies of the Python data
ecosystem and that that was it sounds
like something that we would just have a
secondary reason of choosing tasks but
it definitely was one of the main
reasons it totally adheres to our
philosophy of embracing that the open
source nests and that beauty of the of
the Python data ecosystem and also it
has many many other nice advantages like
it's very well deployable
it works with things like jar to be
deployed in the in the enterprise so
it's already Enterprise capable is not a
academic distributed environment by any
means and also is the most commonly used
for pure Python libraries it's it
it addresses quite some of the kind of
disadvantages of the spark approach
particularly not being Python native you
have to go through PI spark and it's not
exactly berry Python II dusk is very
very very Python II totally follows for
example the data frame API specification
by pandas as much as possible they array
specification by nan PI and it just
feels right if you are a Python
developer and finally the other
component that is under the hood and I
just wanted to mention because it's
pretty cool and it's something that
users want know but it's something that
is being provided not only for GPUs by
any means is open you see X and open you
see X is our communication Larry that is
being plugged into tasks and other
distributed libraries that accelerate
things massive leads
somewhat topology aware Harbor
communication layer so essentially
allows programs that are distributed to
pass messages between them but it knows
how they are connected so for example
you have a network that has InfiniBand
it will juice protocols that are good
for being just my communicator 3
InfiniBand and will give you orders of
magnitude faster speed than traditional
message passing distribution frameworks
and other distributed communication
frameworks of course it also is aware of
a GPUs so you have for example two GPUs
and you decide to buy a really cool and
willing bridge it was just a milling
bridge he won't go through hosts and it
will make your program run orders of
magnitude faster and in the past I was
not sure even if you have an ending
bridge between two GPUs if you didn't do
something like you open you CX your
program could go through the CPU memory
and back to the other GPU memory so that
kind of defeated the purpose of NB link
but open u CX could also work for CPU
clusters and it also has the
optimizations for CPU clusters now the
main optimization and the main way you
can see the performance happen is not in
the computation and highlights one of
the big complications of creating a data
science robust framework is that this
isn't the communication is very hidden
it won't keep you wrong results it will
just be slower unexpectedly so if anyone
has worked with desk does give you this
type of graphs and when it tells you I'm
doing
computations are I'm doing
communications so before we optimize up
in ucx which you could see at graph a
chart like you'd wanna see in the first
half of the slide and the red squares in
that is pure communication the CP or the
processing tasks are waiting just doing
nothing particularly towards the end of
the task so your task your resources are
doing exactly nothing because the
communication layer is not a word that
it had a faster path to send messages
and to make things work together and get
the data where it needed to be
after optimizations you can see you all
can see that there's a lot of less red
code that's kind of the most technical
way I will mention how much faster open
ucx is getting and that will make
scheduling to multi GPUs and multi node
clusters way way way way more efficient
as I mentioned there's a lot of
complexities in scaling to to multi node
to multi-gpu and how so how does this
rapid ecosystem looks like just for for
example how do we create sorry I had to
turn to see that the screen was still on
I get paranoia sometimes so how does our
ecosystem look compared to the wonderful
scikit-learn based one that we sought to
create a logistic relation with a CSV
well that was already the second slide
just for anyone that missed it it was
three words of change we have followed
the API is very very closely to keep the
Python data ecosystem as pretty as it is
as much as possible
of course if you want to add
distribution we task to this you will
have your desk code added to it but is
not rapid specific that's code it's the
same task code you would write to
paralyze pandas itself that's the big
philosophy now this philosophy doesn't
stop there and well that's a pretty
graphic of how much speed-up rabbit gets
when we when you do those three words of
change so 100 CPU nodes are orders of
magnitude slower than 1 GPU based
computer but I won't go too much into
that you have seen talks about it you
can go to our website that's a graphic
from our website just wrap it this fast
that's the TLDR but the main key here is
we don't want to just stop and making
rapid v-very pythonic trap it's being
nice to use we want to make it together
with the existing ecosystem I mentioned
that we already followed the api's so
we're going to be familiar the user is
not gonna be scared necessarily about
Rapids but what happens when the user
doesn't want to just use Rapids so the
we have tried to interact with the
ecosystem in many ways and there are
many many many proposals of how to make
different Python libraries interoperable
how to make different libraries talk to
each other essentially so we started
facing a lot of complexity regarding
that and this part of the talk you will
see how many complexities and how much
effort we're putting into making things
work together but that's the point this
talk if we give it again next year it
would look totally different this is
very very much something the latest
changes that have happened to these
things probably were yesterday so this
is very very much what what is happening
right now
but when one good example is phrase for
example random forest everybody's using
random forest estates in the form of XG
boost and light G BM so everybody loves
actually boost for example because it's
for lack of a better description black
magic that kind of just works more than
it should and that's how I like to
describe it she boost it it's a really
great Larry Tamira I love extreme was
that you sexy boost a lot sometimes it
outperforms new neural networks there
are orders of magnitude more complicated
just because it has a great gradient
boosting but num decreasing sorry so but
HG boost
unlike GPM for that matter our
performant for a CPU based
implementation but once you want to go
into production
it happens that extra boost is hard to
scale it's not that easy to just make
extra boost perform really well in big
it really big models particularly when
you want to do the inference side when
you want to predict
observations after you have a trained
model so one of the components that we
introduced was hey let's do a GPU
accelerated forest inference library
because we're very creative with naming
but it's just a library that allows you
to do very very fast inference for
random forests that have been already
trained with XG boost and like GBM now
the issue there is that extra boost like
GBM scikit-learn for that matter and who
AM L our selves
there's no standard or how do you encode
the features of your trained random
forests how do you encode the
coefficients of it the of each decision
tree all the data that you have trained
so that has been a fun a fun adventure
in the past couple of months so right
now what we have achieved is that our
forest inference layer can perform
inference on model strain only on X
eBoost unlike GBM which Saiki learn
coming soon and qu ml itself even later
after cycle learn which is kind of funny
to think about our own random forests
cannot be in France with the forests in
France layer because we were focused on
accelerating inference from X G boost
which is kind of the poster child of the
situation well why was that well we're
outperforming the inference by X G boost
by 30 times as we kind of expect from
GPU based things but it has been a lot
of work because there is no standard so
we have turned to push standards for all
interoperability in many many other ways
and there have been three or four main
ways in three or four main standards
that we have been pushing the first one
was as I mention in the beginning there
are 14 types of device erase or the GPU
based array libraries among them some of
them here GPU somewhere here CPU but at
their core they're all arrays so they're
all memory that is contiguous that is in
CPU on GPU so the way the way numpy has
already seen this problem and they have
been proposals by new by itself to make
libraries interpret with each other one
of the main ones lately has been the
proposal nap 18 which a better name for
it is the array function standard which
is just a function that if your library
implements it can define how to apply
the functions of number to their objects
so is this underscore underscore array
function in which if you have a new
library that implements it you just need
to define this function underscore
underscore array function that takes the
name of the function is gonna be applied
so for example min and it takes the
arguments that he applies to and then it
tells it how do they how to apply them
in to that type of object so a good
example of that is Sai pies Paris
matrices
you're not gonna calculate the mean the
same way in an umpire rate and an aside
buyspares matrix because one is at the
sparse matrix that could be a CEO Oh
matrix that is you have to transform to
be able to calculate the mean for
example so how does this look to the
user
well actually is very nice a few
libraries both employment if they did
they array function
it happens that for example here you can
create a new empire array and then you
can create a task array from the new
array and then apply the new PI in this
case I'm be applying the new n PI dot
alina SVD function to the task array and
it just works because dusk implements
the array function and it tells it hey
when you see a task vector here this is
the way you're going to calculate a mean
or in this case the SVD function in a
task array so it's very very nice for
the users it has a great result but it
has and you can change this day later
for example to Kupa which also applies
the the same function and now I'm
sending to noon PI to PI arrays which
are totally GPU device arrays it's not
even CPU but it has quite a few
disadvantages that have made its
adoption
slower than what we would have hoped
particularly some of them is that it is
a relatively big commitment as you saw
it assumes that the functions you can
apply follow the same conventions as
numpy so if you had written a library
who instead of calling the mean you
called it average and then you have
different type of arguments it's gonna
be a harder burden for your library to
adopt this standard and knowing that for
things like scipy and sparse matrices
they were following an older type of API
for storing the data based on noon
Python matrix instead of know by door in
the array
which is like the modern umpire is that
everybody knows it has been a lot of
work there are github issues that have
lots of comments of how much work is
needed to eventually be able to have
scifi matrices be just accepted by new
by using this standard and of course
there are four libraries for example
like pi torch there's worry so hey this
could break backwards compatibility with
the function we had ridden before we
have to rewrite a lot of code so I'm not
only that oedema today is tricky to be
transparent to the users if one of the
Larry's I was showing you in the code
here is not
arrey function aware chances are that
numpy might invisibly transfer your data
into an oompa array which if it's in GPL
can be an expensive operation
apply the function I return your numpy
array which was not what you sent it
originally and then the user could be
confused or things could be performing
badly without the user even getting a
warning so those are significant
disadvantages of the of this approach
they're having more this dis approach
called function dispatchers which are
just functions that define how to call
functions
I was quite an inch in definition but
there they have been more function
dispatcher type of approaches or for
example the Quan side guys have really
recently introduced called something
called the u array which cannot learn
some of the lessons from the device
function of the array function from non
PI and create a new multiple dispatch
mechanism that is agnostic of the new PI
API for example so you could have your
own definition of API and still manage
to adhere to a standard if you bow
everybody adhere to the you are a
standard of course that makes things a
little more complicated from the tool
development because it's a little more
hard standard to understand and apply
sometimes but it definitely has
advantages over the original numpy
device array the other disadvantage that
it has is that where this advantage and
disadvantage is that the user gets a lot
of control the user can choose which
backends to use on their objects so once
to libraries implement the URA interface
the user for example can can can can can
call the you are a set back end function
and tell it from here on now I can tell
hey use the coop PI back-end for this
and then every time you send an object
to for example n P dot mean it's not
actually when I just known PI is gonna
use coop I and then you could have a
different library that can be used for
that of course that gives a lot of power
to users but adoption has been not so
starting beginning but he still has the
relative burden of implementation on and
on the library developers so there are
quite a few work that they will need to
be done eventually to to see it
implemented in
all the libraries like pi torch number
and many others know if you have been
seeing what I have where I started the
presentation this begs the question hey
didn't you say that arrow started as a
common memory interface so that
everybody can talk with each other yes
absolutely and there's a lot of things
that has the arrow aware or are based on
Harold like us that's a clear example it
has he has quite a few advantages for
things like data frames columnar based
so it allows you to be do certain
operations very fast but for other
levers like machine library like sorry
like machine learning it doesn't have
those advantages so the adoption in
machine learning and deep learning has
been relatively slower by the end also
many letters already have the existing
memory format like pi torch MX nate
number well now that the pircuit
deprecated chainer Kupa so it's not as
easy as saying hey everybody changed to
arrow and start talking with each other
so in that sense the way that I drop it
we have done interoperability
besides being based on arrow is with two
more lightweight approaches than the
Moonpie device array interface the
number device array functions sorry
there are DL pack and CUDA interface and
the second one is very close to my heart
so I might talk a little bit better
about the second one but both are just
essentially very simple kind of
agreements or standards in which if you
adhere to you can see objects from the
other standard so they could be by
Sunday they could ever interface has
already implemented by noon Burcu pi pi
torch and it is a dictionary that if
your objects implement that happens that
the other libraries can see that
dictionary and read the data immediately
so you I can get the memory pointers
from a number array or a PI touch array
and also in does there isn't Who am L
for example can accept
PI torch number qu PI R mmm and of
course the general imperative erase the
first for without a custom code is the
same exact call because we all accept
the CUDA ray interface and implementing
it can be a simple as 10 to 20 lines of
code depending on certain needles of
your library but it's way like more
lightweight and here is kind of the
I'm almost running out of time but here
is kind of a very simple example of the
type of workflow that was describing as
an objective at the beginning it's a
super simple example but you're just
creating accurate a torch tensor in pi
torch then you are using coop I to
calculate the norm of the torch tensor
without compression or anything and then
you're calculating the DB scan
clustering in that same using the same
data that if you notice that just feels
like magic because it was a PI torch
object that being processed by could KU
PI and then being processed by qml
without the juice earning anything and
the original tensor are still being
there so you can imagine how you could
go back to PI torch and still process
things back in the original library that
this is the case already there of course
many layers I have not implemented CUDA
interface for time it requires of course
also things but the main advantage is
that there are no compressions by the
user there is no memory copy underneath
so there is no loss of efficiency
there's a reduced user coming field
allowed the user hand doesn't have to be
thinking about converting the data order
time and keeping track of what they did
what format their data is in and whether
they can send it to a library or not and
the user still keeps a lot of control
they know what library what function in
what library they're gonna be using it's
not necessarily chosen for them
underneath because of a function
dispatcher of course it has
disadvantages among them memory
ownership can be tricky this is a
disadvantage in the distributed
environment a little bit because we when
you want to register with data it
happens that we have to create a copy of
the data there's a loss of efficiency
there we're trying to deal with the cuda
interface doesn't transfer the memory
ownership to a library that's applying
the function so we cannot modify it even
if the user would like that
the version has been changing a little
bit so some library sometimes a little
bit and the user still keeps a lot of
control that I put it also as a
disadvantage because that's a little
more user cognitive load and then might
be ideal for first-time commerce they
they might be why doesn't this Larry
provide all the functions I want why is
it trying to tell me to use these other
librarians
so it might have it might also be a
scene as a as a weakness and then
finally I'll mention DL pack which is a
very similar standard but it's for
entire Beller it started as a standard
for interoperability of deep learning
libraries so it's a tensor format that
you adhere to then you can convert to DL
pack and a lot of libraries can read the
L pack could EF impractical another is
supports DL pack and therefore we can
talk with PI torch MX net change with
compressions to DL pack from a data
frame for example and the day the once
again the code ends up being very very
simple so for example from wine from a
coupie array that supports DL pack into
a coup DF data frame which is the panda
style data frame you need to convert the
Cooper array to the L pack which
depending on the data originally might
not even require a copy might just be
manipulating pointers and then could EF
can receive the DL pack function even
though Koopa is not an arrow based array
necessarily now there are a few other
interesting alternatives there's things
like Koopa get array module that I will
just mentioned that in which the user
calls the method from Koopa with an
object and then Koopa returns you the
library that can apply functions to that
so here for example XP could be numpy or
could be Koopa and the user doesn't need
to know but coop I chose what was the
better library if to call things in that
object so then library developers and
users can write library agnostic code
this is something that we're extending
which are what coop is doing for future
development because it's an option that
allows a lot of freedom both from the
developer perspective and the user
perspective now as you saw there are
many kind of competing approaches or
different approaches that is because
interoperability can be pretty hard and
tricky as you saw some people lack in a
plane in supporting the new empire
standard some people lack in support and
could array interface standard so we're
trying to do many approaches and seeing
what happens because there is very
definitely and it is definitely a very
new field the CUDA interface was
introduced not so along it since version
2 which was introduced I think a month
ago or so which of course broke
dependency so we had to do
with the lack of dependencies obtaining
the Refresh of the CUDA interface all of
this is happening very very recently a
new version of coop I was released six
hours ago the results are back with the
CUDA interface so as you can see a lot
of things are moving but at the end of
the day as these mature this allows
users a lot more freedom without losing
the simplicity of Python without
becoming a simple as plus thing that you
require a lot of comparisons and gives
you a lot of control but with the
trade-off of losing productivity of your
view of your users and that's kind of
the overview or the slightly deep dive
into how inter probability's working in
the GPU open open-source Python data
science ecosystem so hope you have
enjoyed the talk so far
it also has have a blast light but I
think I want to give a little bit of
time to questions five minutes but it
has also allows us to simplify our
continuous integration test and unit
test significantly but if you have any
questions feel free to ask and of course
open source rapid feel free to join the
movement but thank you very much so
there's a lot of tools another hood here
with Rapids so I imagine the most
difficult probably maintenance side is
the incompatibilities that crop up
whenever people make changes have you
kind of recommended for people to kind
of keep track of that or deal with
upgrading their dependencies to keep
both their models working and to not lag
so far behind that stuff won't work in
the future yeah so definitely there the
question if someone here's how to deal
essentially with dependencies and
conflicts of dependencies which is a
tricky problem overall in a in an
ecosystem that have also fast Rapids
introduced a new version every six weeks
tries to not break things but it's
impossible to guarantee that there are
quite a few strategies to be used among
them using
presently I'm a big advocate of Conda to
try to have version control of your
environments but besides that trying to
put trying to push libraries to support
more of this interoperability standards
will help significantly because once you
support the standards you can regress
yuju data is going to be interoperable
even with generations of that library
that support the same standard
so for example if you see that
scikit-learn 0.22 broke your code
because whatever reason but you had
already processed some of you some of
your arrays in scikit-learn 0.22
and scikit-learn could support some of
these standards you could regress your
library easily and then still the
process things with the same with the
similary different version so another
thing that I didn't mention enough that
is that these standards can help that
interoperability between different
versions because if the object still
helps with things and you see that your
library has box with different versions
that you can immediately start
regressing things without having to
retrain our reader on the workflow and
entirely from from scratch and of course
there in the more general sense things
like Kanta and docker are definitely
some of the best solutions that are out
there but it's a very active topic not
only for users and data scientist but
also for us developers something we're
trying to solve the kondeh I think one
of the biggest possible solutions is
Condor they have done a great job but it
still also Jang and evolving very very
fast condor forage is a great movement
everybody's trying to who contribute to
Condor forage we are trying to
contribute Condor forage but there's a
lot of conversations happening because
not only is the dependents producers
each library has a lot of dependencies
that hasn't taken care of at the
operative system level and that's a lot
of decisions for the channels of
distribution in conda's so it's
something that will improve but for now
I would say that docker kondeh and
standards like these are gonna help
significantly and feel free to also drop
a questioning it hub for any particular
issue or a more specific question or
grab us offline for sure it's something
I respond a lot of users I get a lot of
those questions and I help a lot of
users particularly in the qu ml machine
learning repository very very often
thank you very much everyone
you